herr kanzleramtsminister seit gestern
gibt es zumindest ein wenig lockerung
aber viele bürger beschweren sich auch
über ja eine art chaos sie verstehen
nicht warum zum beispiel leben bis zu
800 quadratmeter wieder öffnen dürfen
aber kirchen nicht warum ist das so
zunächst einmal geht es ja darum dass
auch jetzt mit dem zwanzigsten april die
epidemie nicht verschwunden ist sondern
sie ist in unserem land und sie wird uns
noch eine ganze weile begleiten und
deshalb ist das was wir jetzt versuchen
in kleinen schritten zum normalen leben
zurückzukehren
aber dabei eben darauf zu achten dass
ansteckung wo immer das möglich ist
vermieden werden und deshalb alles was
versammlungen sind wo man länger
zusammensitzt und dazu gehören auch
gottesdienste sind dinge die wir im
ersten schritt jetzt noch nicht
ermöglichen aber sind in einem
intensiven gespräch mit den
religionsgemeinschaften wann und wie wir
das auch wieder ermöglichen können das
liegt uns auch am herzen und ist wichtig
und was den einzelhandel angeht geht es
eben darum dass wir zwar geschäft für
geschäft sicherstellen können dass dort
möglichst keine ansteckungen passieren
aber wenn sie sich einen normalen
samstag mit vollen innenstädten
vorstellen dann ist das natürlich auch
ein problem und deshalb müssen die
publikumsmagneten die großen geschäfte
noch für diesen moment geschlossen
bleiben damit wir erst mal sehen was
diese belebung der innenstädte jetzt bei
den geschäften bis zu 800 quadratmetern
gewirkt aber wenn man jetzt mit
besitzern von größeren geschäften
spricht 800 quadratmeter dann sagen die
diese neue regelung macht überhaupt
keinen sinn denn in unseren geschäften
könnten wir so viel abstand halten wie
eben in kleinen geschäften nicht möglich
also wo ist da die logik warum kleine
offen und große nicht offen wo man doch
am besten ab standhalten könnte ja weil
es eben nicht nur um die frage geht wie
es in den geschäften zugeht sondern auch
wissen der innenstadt insgesamt zugeht
und
wenn man sich eine shopping mall mit
20.000 quadratmeter vorstellt wo man
dann bis zu 1000 kunden gleichzeitig
zulässt dann hat es das natürlich von
der abstandsregel her im geschäft okay
aber die parkplätze die die ganze
innenstadt situation der öffentliche
personennahverkehr
dann kommt es zu einer belebung der
innenstädte wo man einfach sagen muss
das ist jetzt als allererster schritt
einfach wirklich zu viel sondern die
kleinen geschäfte mit überschaubarer
kundenzahl
die machen jetzt wieder auf und dann
müssen wir uns die infektionszahlen sehr
sehr genau anschauen denn eins wollen
wir glaube ich alle nicht dass wir jetzt
zu viele maßnahmen ergreifen und uns
dann die epidemie wieder davon läuft wie
anfang märz damals war es ja so dass
jeder der sich infiziert hat im schnitt
drei bis fünf leute angesteckt hat und
das hätte innerhalb weniger wochen zu
einer überforderung unseres
gesundheitssystems geführt mit bildern
mich in italien oder spanien und das
haben wir jetzt durch viel disziplin
vermieden und diesen erfolg müssen wir
sichern und deshalb in kleinen schritten
auf dem weg zur normalität
wir müssen natürlich noch für lange zeit
lernen so wie wir es im supermarkt jetzt
schon machen dass wir andere
verhaltensregeln brauchen weil der virus
geht leider leider so schnell nicht weg
fast nebenbei hat gestern der bayerische
ministerpräsident markus söder in der
pressekonferenz gesagt dass
großveranstaltungen bis zum 31 august
nicht stattfinden dürfen wie definieren
sie großveranstaltung also ganz sicher
mal veranstaltungen über 1000 teilnehmer
aber wenn wir uns mal die situation
heute angucken momentan sind ja
veranstaltungen im grunde genommen
gänzlich untersagt und auf der strecke
muss man über die die teilnehmerzahl
immer noch mal reden denn
veranstaltungen sind einfach das haben
wir jetzt als erfahrungswert ein großes
problem
der ausbruch in heinsberg war durch eine
faschingsveranstaltung wir haben jetzt
die bayerischen starkbierfest gab die
solche probleme hervorgerufen haben
und auch der april war er einer der
wesentlichen auslöser für eine starke
verbreitung des corona virus und deshalb
haben wir gestern das signal gesetzt
wer große veranstaltungen jetzt auch
über den sommer hinweg plant das ergibt
keinen sinn da brauchen wir noch eine
ganze längere dauer wo wir sowas
vermeiden weil einfach große
veranstaltungen der zentrale überträger
sind wenn wir mal schauen was wir bisher
erlebt haben aber auch sie nennen jetzt
wieder keine zahlen gestern hat wolfgang
bosbach zu uns gesagt er fragt sich
jetzt zum beispiel aber die hochzeit
seiner tochter planen darf im sommer
also gilt es zum beispiel auch für
familienfeste über 50 über 100 personen
wir müssen das ja immer nicht von der
regelung her denken sondern von vom
virus her und wenn man eine
veranstaltung mit 150 gästen aus dem
ganzen bundesgebiet macht zum beispiel
dann ist das natürlich aus der sicht des
infektionsgeschehen momentan auch nicht
gut und insofern haben wir jetzt eine
situation wo wir ja gänzlich solche
veranstaltungen nicht machen und im
august dann auch sicher keine über 1000
und wir werden jetzt auch wenn wir alle
zwei wochen überprüfen
wie das genau weitergeht werden wir die
empfehlungen immer präzisieren und die
botschaft von gestern ging eben darum
ganz große dinge jetzt nicht zu planen
und auch große familienfeste für den
sommer kann man einfach wenn man sich
die lage an guckt auch nicht empfehlen
die gefahr dass man sie kurzfristig
wieder absagen muss bei einfach das
virus auch den ganzen sommer über noch
im land sein wird
die ist einfach zu groß sie haben das
kontaktverbot gerade angesprochen und
die frage wie das jetzt überprüft wird
alle zwei wochen für wann können sie
denn den menschen hoffnung machen dass
man sich wieder mit mehr personen
zumindest mit 345 freunden im park
treffen darf na ja die frage wird sich
jetzt auch sehr stark einmal an den
infektionszahlen festmachen
wir müssen schauen ob wir es schaffen
das wichtigste ist doch jetzt dass die
wirtschaft schrittweise wieder läuft das
ja wirklich mehrere hundert milliarden
euro jetzt nutzen müssen um die deutsche
wirtschaft zu stabilisieren also da
haben wir eine riesenaufgabe das hat
priorität
das zweite ist natürlich das thema
bildung wir haben die kinder und
jugendlichen sind zu hause die schulen
sind geschlossen und auch da ist ein
langsamer und vorsichtiger weg zurück in
die normalität glaube ich zunächst mal
das aller aller wichtigste und als
drittes kommt eben die frage unsere
freizeitgestaltung und die steht
wirklich an dritter stelle
und deshalb ist diese grund empfehlung
glaube ich noch eine ganze weile einfach
wichtig weil es so lange wir uns so
verhalten wie in den letzten wochen also
im wesentlichen engen kontakt nur zu
unseren familien angehörigen mit dem wir
ohnehin zusammen wohnen
das ist einfach das effektivste mittel
dass wir überhaupt haben um des corona
virus einzudämmen und deshalb bleibt es
noch eine ganze weile wichtig und dann
muss man natürlich im verlauf mal sehen
aber auch die freizeit kontakte werden
anders sein als sie das früher waren
weil auch da wird es weiter gelten das
abstandhalten total wichtig ist sie
sprechen die schulen an auch dort wissen
viele eltern viele schulkinder jetzt
nicht wirklich was passiert
zum einen wurde gesagt dass abiturienten
jetzt als die ersten wieder anfangen
sollen könnte sinn machen das jetzt
prüfungen erst mal stattfinden und dass
man dann in vorgezogene sommerferien
geht und dann alle wieder loslegen was
passiert jetzt also beschlossen haben
wir das ab sofort wenn das vernünftig
vorbereitet ist in den schulen die
prüfungen stattfinden können und auch
prüfungsvorbereitungen de kurse damit
die kinder auch nicht einfach in eine
prüfung rennen müssen ohne vorbereitet
zu sein also prüfungsvorbereitung und
prüfungen sollen ab sofort stattfinden
können wenn die schulen sich darauf
angemessen vorbereitet haben
im nächsten schritt dann ab dem 4 mai
sollen auch diejenigen klassen die ab
nächsten jahr prüfungen haben wieder
geschult werden können
und dann müssen wir wieder schauen wie
sich die infektionszahlen entwickelt
haben
dann müssen erwarten wir auch von der
kultusministerkonferenz einbricht und
ein konzept wie das dann weitergehen
kann
auch das müssen wir schrittweise machen
weil die situation ist einfach so kinder
stecken sich das von allem was wir
wissen relativ leicht an wie man auf
einem grundschul pausenhof
abstandsregeln zur einheit und bringt
das glaube es wäre eine herausforderung
das ist außerordentlich schwierig kinder
haben in der regel einen sehr leichten
verlauf was was das virus angeht aber
sie bringen ihn natürlich auch mit nach
hause und damit sind sie sogenannte
ansteckung brücken und deshalb ist auch
das thema wie organisieren wir die
hygiene in den schulen welche
erfahrungen machen wir jetzt mit den
älteren ganz wichtig und dafür auch dann
für die jüngeren schulklassen etwas zu
lernen wie man das in der schule am
besten umsetzt und deshalb ist leider
krone etwas was uns allen wirklich viel
geduld ab fordert zum abschluss herr
braun haben wir die frage eines wirtes
vorbereitet sam kamran aus frankfurt der
eine frage an sie hat ich grüße sie herr
braun
das hat mich auch gerade eingelesen sie
sind ja arzt und sogar und auch
professor
die frage ist warum wird die
gastronomische vernachlässigt warum
dürfen autohäuser eröffnen und
gastronomie nicht es geht ja auch ein
bisschen um die stimmung der menschen
weil die sind ja inzwischen bisschen
psychisch angeschlagen ja das verstehe
ich und ich vermisse auch das
zusammentreffen der gastronomie aber
gastronomie ist eben wie ich gesagt habe
ein ort der geselligkeit und sozusagen
neben den wesentlichen bereichen jetzt
bildung und produktion müssen wir darauf
achten dass die menschen abstand halten
und dass es eben im geselligen kontext
dazu gehört leider auch die gastronomie
einer unserer ganz großen
herausforderungen und deshalb werden wir
jetzt den ersten schritt gemacht können
wir die gast
wenn wir jetzt noch nicht öffnen aber
deshalb können wir uns hier auch und
unterstützen auch gastronomen wie andere
kleine selbstständigen mit unserem
sofortprogramm aber die öffnung der
gastronomie führt sozusagen wieder zu
mehr freizeit kontakten und man sitzt ja
in der gastronomie jetzt selten mit den
menschen mit denen man zusammen wohnen
sondern mit freunden und bekannten
und das ist eben das große die große
herausforderung von corona das genau das
eigentlich gerade nicht stattfinden soll
da kann man hat ihnen das weiter
geholfen dann haben sie noch eine
nachfrage an den kanzleramtsminister
herz ist ihre chance
das hatte ich erwartet denn ich verstehe
das auch das problem ist halt nur
wirklich dass unsere qualität aus geld
kann ich bin ja ein größerer gastronom
und die soforthilfen sie nicht gekommen
die kredite sind nicht angekommen und
die versicherung also die rücken kein
cent raus dann hat den
liquiditätsproblemen und dann muss die
politik mehr druck machen
also wenn die programme nicht ankommen
das ist sicherlich ein punkt bin ich
dann gerne auch mal bereit nachzuschauen
woran das eigentlich liegt der abflüsse
sehr programme sind eigentlich momentan
relativ gut also viele profitieren davon
aber manchmal gibt es lücken das muss
man sich dann anschauen
aber es ist eben leider die wahrheit
dass wir der gastronomie jetzt noch
nicht ganz kurzfristig ein angebot
machen können wann sie wieder aufmacht
herzlichen dank herr kanzleramtsminister
dass sie sich zeit genommen haben heute
morgen herzlichen dank herr kamran für
ihre frage bleiben sie beide gesund und
alles gute